only last year we said that we weren't
going to invest
in overseas uh coal mining
uh this year as you say just uh today we
will unveil the fact that
about 190
countries and organizations are going to
be signed up to phasing out coal
um and across the world people realize
that uh coal is going to be a thing of
the past we're consigning coal to
history so i think it's a really
impressive step
yeah but china and u.s not signed up is
that right
well we're working with
chinese negotiators
as well as the united states and of
course you know that the united states
certainly under president biden is
taking its climate commitments
extremely seriously uh and even in china
uh they've announced that they're not
going to be investing in overseas uh
coal mining so that's a big step
obviously we want to go further but i
don't think we should play down the
significance
of of today's announcements okay what's
going to happen to the uh new white
haven coal mine
uh that as i always say is a planning
issue it's not something which
i can determine as a secretary of state
and it's going to be reviewed it is
being reviewed by the relevant planning
authority
yeah but if we're saying the end of curl
is in sight obviously we don't want to
work in more coal mines do we
no but we've had a huge success
uh in moving away from coal
really only in the last 10 years
in 2012
40 of our electricity was from coal
today it's only one percent
um and as far as that particular coal
mine is concerned as i've said uh that's
something which is uh part of an
independent planning process
yeah but you appreciate that if we're
saying that the end of cole is in sight
which is a quote that we're using this
morning what the government's saying and
then talking about opening a new coal
mine i mean the juxtaposition of those
two is not going to sit comfortably with
my viewers this morning is it
now understand uh your point but as i
keep saying
as far as the coal uh
mining cumbria was concerned that was a
process that was started
some years ago and at the moment it's
something that's an independent
uh planning decision and it would not be
right for me as a minister uh to comment
on the on the rights and wrongs of it
don't see why not
well it's an independent process so what
happens is that you have people uh like
me ministers making uh political policy
uh uh calls and then if you have a
planning uh situation it often goes
through the relevant planning authority
and if there's an appeal that is an
independent process and at the moment
it's currently being investigated so it
wouldn't be right for me uh to say uh
one way or the other what i think is
going to happen
okay
so the government abides by independent
process
a tory mp
is paid 500 000 pounds
by two companies to lobby on their
behalf
he's found guilty because it's against
the rules
he's suspended from parliament for 30
days
the ruling conservative party you guys
vote to change the rules
why
so it wasn't uh it's not about the
rights and wrongs of what owen patterson
uh said or did or or how he was paid i
think the process is something that we
want to look at the fact is he had no
right of appeal and we feel that in
terms of parliament
people should have a right of appeal as
they do
in most employments
throughout this country so as far as i
know because i've been here all week as
you you appreciate as far as i know and
i've read the issue about the issue and
been told about it um the vote yesterday
was all about you know getting a proper
process
and getting some sort of right of appeal
uh that mps of all parties uh can rely
on uh in in a case like this it's not
about the rights and wrongs of what owen
did or didn't do
it's about trying to get it to know it's
about trying to get for no no it isn't
it's about
the andrew i mean i read the what andrea
ledson's amendment was about and that
was all about you know setting up a
committee and setting up a right of
appeal process
uh in a in a case like this i don't
think it was particularly related to
what
owen said or did
he took half a million quid to lobby on
behalf of two companies which are
against the rules as a result the
independent body which you say you abide
by independent thought um has decided
that he has to be suspended for 30 days
half a million pounds people are
struggling to feed their kids he takes
half a million quid and you you move the
goal posts
so as i said okay it's the vote
yesterday and i wasn't there but i've
read about it the vote yesterday and
you're closer to it
you're closer to it than i am frankly oh
stop it
stop it i mean i'm in glasgow i'm in
glasgow geographically i might be closer
but you know exactly what's going on
that that's duplicitous to say that
minister come on no no it's not they i
mean looking at what happened yesterday
uh and i read the motion and i saw
bits of the debate it was it was all
about the process the vote was about
getting a system of fairness uh back
uh into uh
almost what might be a kind of
employment uh tribunal i mean my
department looks after employment
tribunal looks after workers rights and
throughout this country people would
have any employee would have a right of
appeal this is something that owen
doesn't have didn't have and we're
trying to get that back into the
parliamentary process i'm not here to
comment on what he did or how much money
he was making or anything like that i
think there was an issue with the
process i think the system had broken
down
and we want to reform it
have you ever taken money for promoting
uh a company's products
no i haven't i'm a minister so why would
you not well i'm i'm a minister uh in
the government so there are rules
against just a clarification um if the
government are so concerned about uh
standards process why is it changing the
rules 90 minutes
on the very day that one of your
colleagues is being suspended if you
were so offended by the system why was
it not changed before now
so kate i mean you you'll appreciate i'm
sure that we've been talking about this
for years we've been talking about
holding mps to account having the
highest standards uh in public life uh
ways in which we can improve uh those
standards and make people more
accountable we've been talking about
these sorts of things for for many years
now and and it so happens that yesterday
we
passed a vote
narrow vote i think uh in favor of
actually trying to get a more rigorous
process where people would could have a
right of appeal and that's what uh my
understanding of what happened yesterday
in parliament was all about completely
coincidental that it was the same day
that um irene patterson was going to be
suspended for 30 days for uh breaching
the rules it's a dark day for democracy
says chris brian 50 conservative mps
agree and they divide the three-line
whip explaining to my viewers a
three-line whip is basically when you
are told that this is what you have to
do 50 conservative mps said i'm sorry
we're not having that how can you defend
the government on this one
well just just on that i mean 50 mps
were out but i was one of them so many
people were doing
other things they were doing um you know
government business lots of people here
at this world uh conference
um so it doesn't mean that that because
50 people didn't vote uh yesterday
were you paired with the labels
why did you not vote just just explain
that to our viewers
because i i'm in glasgow and were you
paired with it with a labor mp
negated
okay i wasn't paired i was slipped so i
was i was essentially been here you're
getting into all the technicalities now
and frankly my viewers really don't care
at all what they care about is that
you're that the the government was
telling mps which way they had to vote
and your tory mps was saying absolutely
not this is
totally unacceptable and in fact when
the result came through many of them
were shouting shame do you feel shame
this morning
i don't feel shame at all i didn't see
the vote coming in
but it was an independent process it was
an independent vote at parliament uh and
i'm i'm really interested in seeing the
system uh reformed and and made
more just and fair by allowing people a
right of appeal
uh not independent if it's whip though
is it
not i don't know about that
okay you said you didn't want to talk
about is it an independent vote or not
it's not an independent vote if it's
whip so it's not independent is it
well as you said lots of people didn't
vote lots of people uh the number of
people voted against the government
and it was a expressway of parliament
we're getting down in the weeds aren't
we here the point is this guy took half
a million quid for lobbying people he
shouldn't have done it he got he was
told that he had to be suspended for 30
days you moved the goal post so he
didn't have to um my viewers watching
this morning will think sleaze sleeves
sleeve sleeves sleaze
they may do but i don't think it's about
that at all i think it's about trying to
make sure that someone who's been
accused of something has a right of
appeal
okay new committee is what's being set
up labour and the snp
on the previous committee's so outraged
just saying that they're not going to
sit on this committee it's just not um
not something that they want to do
it's not the right way for democracy
going forward you're still going to go
ahead with the committee
i think we won't i mean that was what
was expressed in the vote yesterday
i think there'll be a uh this morning i
have to say
what no i think look i think it was a
vote yesterday the house of commons made
its will expressed and we feel that
there needs to be a right of appeal for
any mp from any party uh that was in the
same situation who's been accused of
really quite serious uh serious
wrongdoing oh it is serious wrongdoing
yeah we've established that this is not
about what he did or didn't do it's
about trying to get a fair process uh
the public's concerned it's about what
he did and didn't do he took half a
million quid in order to influence uh
the government basically that's what he
did and the independent commission said
that's not acceptable that's what my
viewers are interested in this morning
further he then goes on to say i'd do it
again
owen patterson has a right as anyone
else does in any employment
uh to appeal against a sentence or any
kind of judgment
uh
in in this instance he didn't have that
right of appeal the vote yesterday was
all about trying to get a fairer system
uh in place
he said that the commissioner should
resign do you think she should
i think it's difficult uh to see
what the future of the of the
commissioner is given the fact that
we're reviewing the process and we're
overturning
and trying to
reform
this whole process but it's up to the
commissioner to decide her position
so you think she should
resign
all i've said is that we're trying to
reform the process and i think that's
what i'm very focused on uh as a
parliamentarian she should review her
position i think is what you said
it's up to her to do that i mean it's up
to anyone in the where they've made a
judgment and uh
people have sought uh to to change that
to consider their position that's a
natural thing but i'm not saying she
should uh she should resign
just before i let you go
what would you say to my viewers this
morning who say
tories with their noses in the trough
again
i would say that
in their employment in their workplace
if they were accused of anything they
would expect a fair hearing and also
they would expect a right of appeal
and that all we're trying to do is to
bring that in are you saying it wasn't a
fair hearing in westminster are you
saying it wasn't a fair hearing
i'm saying that you would have a right
of appeal even if it was a fair hair
very entitled to a fair hearing are you
saying it wasn't a fair hearing you you
you would yeah i'm not i'm saying that
you're entitled to a fair hearing and
you're entitled to a right of appeal
why was it not fair here okay okay okay
what i'm trying to say is that he did
not have a right of appeal you accept
that and that's why i don't accept that
no i don't accept that at all i also i'm
challenging you on whether you're saying
it was a fair here it's not a fair
hearing you know it was a hearing that
went on for a significant amount of time
we know that it went on a little longer
than potentially it might have been
because of sad personal circumstances
that mr patterson had to deal with but
he was able to speak to the hearing
there was an opportunity for written
testimony from all sorts of witnesses
all of that was taken into account and
then the independent committee decided
that on balance um he'd taken money that
he shouldn't have taken or certainly
shouldn't have been campaigning for
those businesses given that he had taken
money and as a result he needed to be
suspended for 30 days uh 90 minutes
before that the government decided that
they're going to change the rules so
that he doesn't have to be those are the
headlines
so as i've said repeatedly on this
program he did not have a right of
appeal and you've accepted that and
that's what the critical point is and
that's why the vote happened yesterday
and it was it was passed
and you're completely comfortable with
that decision this morning minister
you're completely comfortable with that
i'm comfortable with uh the vote in the
house of commons because that's how
parliamentary democracy works
okay i think you might be asked this a
few times this morning so i better let
you go thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the programme this morning